heute nacht ist eine magische welt in
der ich die katze kühlung wie ein neues
leben verdient ich kann diesen film
leider nicht loben das ist es die
verfilmung des musicals von 1981 und die
verfilmung war einfach eine blöde idee
[Musik]
genau das muss ich habe jetzt ein paar
mal den trailer im kino gesehen vorher
und immer hat das publikum so verlegen
so verwirrt angeekelt gelacht was glaube
ich daran liegt dass diese technik mit
denen mit der die katzen gesichter auf
die gesichter der schauspieler
projiziert wird
die macht ein irgendwie unbehaglich das
ist so ein bisschen creepy es ist das
entspricht nicht unseren sehgewohnheiten
und da bin ich davon ausgegangen die
lachen alle erst mal aus einem
[Musik]
ungewohnten gefühl sondern unwohlsein
gut das wird so nicht funktionieren oder
das sage ich zu dir
das wird aber einfach noch schlimmer
wenn man den film anschaut und es wird
auch nicht besser nach zehn minuten ich
dachte man gewöhnt sich vielleicht daran
dass ist nicht eingetreten
stattdessen fällt einem nach zehn
minuten auf wie seltsam die leute sich
bewegen alb zur halb mensch den katzen
haben nun mal keine knie menschen haben
knie es fällt sehr auf wenn man das
sieht in dem film
ich kann
es gibt sehr sehr viele figuren in cats
verwirrend viele figuren sie haben alle
namen aber man muss sie sich nicht alle
merken
relevant ist die junge katze die am
anfang dazu kommen die wird gespielt von
schönster hayward die prima ballerina am
londoner ballett ist und zum ersten mal
in einem film spielt sie hat nicht viel
zu reden aber sie tanzt dann gibt es alt
deuteronimus das ist eine alte weise
katze im musical eigentlich ein kater
jetzt eine katze die entscheiden darf
welche von den katzen am ende des abends
aufsteigen darf in den sphärischen raum
wie kannst du dich am meisten verdient
bekommt ein neues leben geschenkt und
weil es natürlich ein bösewicht geben
muss gibt es mehr cavity der unbedingt
in den zwischenraum aufsteigen will und
die anderen nach und nach verschwinden
lässt die seine konkurrenten sind zeit
ist gekommen die wahl zu treffen
es ist alles ein bisschen sonderbar aber
alle katzen wollen dass eben die an dem
abend dann sofort tanzen und sich selbst
vorstellen mit diesen liedern alle
lieder beschreiben ja eben einzelne
katzen das sind zur selbstpräsentation
eigentlich eine nummernrevue
das liegt daran dass diese gedichte von
ts eliot auf den musikern basiert da ist
es eben so dass jedes gedicht eine katze
beschreibt die oder die katze beschreibt
sich selbst und das sind dann eben auch
die lieder in dem film aber viel mehr
erfahren wir eben nicht über diese
katzen das heißt die eine katze ist
gemütlich und jagt gerne mäuse und die
andere katze die ist so ein bisschen
frech und dann ist die andere katze die
macht gerne sachen kaputt
das trägt fast zwei stunden film einfach
nicht an charakterentwicklung
die einzige die es wirklich rausreißen
kann dass der film so undankbar ist
gegenüber seinen schauspielern ist
jennifer hudson jennifer hudson spielt
isabella die traurige katze die keiner
mehr markt in meinen star war die jetzt
zurückkommt und arm ist und einsam und
alleine und jennifer hudson singt und
weint dabei die ganze zeit ist das
einzige was sie tut in dem film singen
und weinen und jennifer hudson weint
nicht schön sondern sie meint hässlich
ist also ernst daran merkt man dass
immer mehr hollywood filmen
sie weint so hässlich dass während sie
singt wir sehen wie der rotz aus ihrer
nase in ihren mund rein läuft und
trotzdem ist jennifer hudson gut das ist
die herausragende leistung des films
[Musik]
die party fand das ist das traurige an
den filmen dass so viele tolle
schauspieler dabei sind tom hooper der
regisseur hat auch lisa rabe gedreht das
ist ein guter mann
der choreograf hat hamilton
choreografiert lauter tolle leute und
der film bringt so überhaupt nicht
hast du lust ein neues leben zu beginnen
im vorfeld hieß es der film wäre
eigentlich was für paris also für leute
die angetörnt werden von fell kostümen
und es auch gerne selbst tragen
ich nehme an das muss man genauso sagen
weil man sieht sehr viele leute die
nichts anhaben außer katzen kostüm
irritierenderweise haben sie echte hände
dabei aber keine richtigen füße also es
wirkt alles auch irgendwie nicht so
richtig durchdacht
ansonsten würde ich sagen das reicht auf
jeden fall nicht musical filme zu mögen
und katzen zu mögen das hätte ich
gemerkt vielleicht ist es gut wenn man
noch sehr sehr jung ist ich glaube
kinder würden es lieben ich hätte sicher
geliebt als kind heute funktioniert es
nicht mehr
[Musik]